your videos are boring so I got a
question from maybe a comment from one
of my YouTube viewers still love you
guys Victor who wrote in to say hi Evan
I'm trying not to say your videos are
boring but try something really new like
videos on things we don't know are you
playing a game or something that can
surprise us but I like your videos
Victor dude a hurts man I heard that
hits you right here I've done videos of
me singing and dancing and taking you on
a tour of my condo and growing sprouts
and jumping in the freezing cold grotto
water but if you want a video of me
playing a game then I'm gonna do one for
you because you asked okay and hopefully
you won't find the channel boring
although I don't know how exciting it is
to watch me play a game but we'll see
Kristina can work some magic so I'm
gonna load up League of Legends my
favorite game right now and hopefully we
do well okay so I'm gonna load up my
League of Legends League of Legends is a
game where you you fight five on five
playing against other people you play
with people in against other people and
it was introduced to me by Jason who's
on my team and I'm going to login I am
believe team if you're gonna want to
find me so I always like to play unique
characters and in strange positions I
don't like playing the positions that
everybody else plays and sometimes it
gets me into trouble there's a set of
rules called the meta which is the
status quo what everybody else plays and
I always like to break the meta so I
like to play let's see let's build let's
join a team I'm gonna pick team oh and
in general Teemo is hated people don't
like Teemo there are these bracelets
that do I have one let me find the Teemo
bracelet there are these bracelets that
go out here oh let me bring up here
let's say I love Teemo or you flip it
and it says I hate Teemo so very
controversial figure I'm gonna flip it
to the I love Teemo and of course that's
what part of Lee what attracted me to
the character
gotta cause some controversy not do what
everybody else is doing so on top of
playing a character that a lot of people
don't like I also play him in a position
so there's five positions on the map and
I play him in a position that is very
unusual and you get a lot of hate for it
so let's see join a group I'm the last
player in let's send some love here hi
guys here we go
hashtag believe I'm gonna click ready oh
I didn't get any hate so we're on so
often here so these are the other four
players I'm going to go up against a lot
of times when they see Teemo in the
jungle I get comments like Teemo can't
jungle you can't do Teemo in the jungle
and people will leave the game before we
even get started they'll quit on me
because they don't like the character
that I picked but sometimes people are
they leave good comments and they say I
like seeing the innovation I like seeing
that we're trying something new here
this is great but most of the time we
get hate but luckily these guys even
said anything good or bad so that's a
good start alright matches found the
game was about to begin so what I then
do when a new match is starting I'll go
to my favorite law of compare and league
of legends compare and you put in any
name so my name is believe team and it
tells you who you're up against so this
is my team this is me here and these are
the people on my team and you can see
how good they are so I'm level you know
I have a thousand points this guy's
really good 2,000 points 909 is good and
here's who were going up against and the
character so the enemy jungler is here
so he's sixteen hundred points that he's
better than me so that'll be that'll be
fun and we have a 51 percent chance of
losing only forty eight percent forty
eight point nine percent chance of
winning so it's actually pretty close
and write the name of the game League of
Legends by a company called Wright
usually does a pretty good job of
matching people up this is about to
begin we're waiting for everybody to get
connected
depends on everybody's internet speed so
I'm here at 90% almost and who's the
slowest Oh 5% 0% actually this isn't so
bad
because sometimes you get lag which you
know you're waiting for a response from
the computer and their enemy jungler who
I'm gonna be going up against at some
point is has a slow connection so I
might I might get a little unfair
advantage there with with the lag
there's a song I like to play when I
play Teemo called Astro Teemo and it can
be kind of annoying but I like it
the kids like it it's and it's it's 10
hours 10 hours of Teemo so we'll put it
on for a little bit I don't know how it
clearly comes out on the microphone but
we'll have that as some nice background
music as I'm playing here this is taking
a long time to get in game this this
person's connection is really slow it
looks like we're about to get started
everybody is that 100% so we're gonna
get in let's go
here we go so I'm gonna buy some stuff
everybody buys different items since I'm
gonna be in the jungle I buy items that
are helping me in the jungle
and I always like to say good luck have
fun I'll spread some love
so they're different there's three lanes
that you fight and then all that dark
area is the jungle so that's where I
play I play in the land where nobody can
see what's going on and I'm going to ask
for some help there put a trinket
so the map becomes more visible as you
walk over the areas but it's dangerous
being in the jungle because enemies
could be in the middle and you don't see
them so part of my job is to set up
vision for everybody so we can we can
not get killed so the big map is here
and then the mini-map is down here so we
can kind of see where we are so I'm
gonna ask for some help your tails full
loaf I don't know what you saying Yolo
yordles is a type of character so I'm
this little Teemo guys a yordle this
this I forget their name poppy is a
yordle and on the other team they have
Lulu who had that problem connecting
that's another yordle here we go okay so
I'm taking out that first monster so the
other players are in their lanes and
they're fighting normal lanes so like
the enemies come in at the same Lane and
then there's one person on each team
called the jungler we just walked
through the jungle so
I'm gonna meet him at some point if I go
into his jungle he comes into mind but
he's stronger at the beginning his
character so I'll have to just run if I
see him no my team is losing one one
kill down so in the beginning phases
usually everybody's in their own lane
and fights aren't too crazy but then as
a game gets later we all seem to bunch
up so so far we've had one kill and
three deaths so we're losing we're not
we're not having a good start to the
game but hopefully it doesn't hurt us
too much
oh there's the enemy yikes he came at me
hard all there's two of them now okay we
made it out of that one
but he's fighting it's a part of my role
is to help influence lanes and support
my my teammates and provide some
two-on-one situations but if I stay too
long and I don't get a kill then I lose
experience and I need to get some goal
to be able to buy some items to make my
character stronger so after you save
that money you can go back to the store
and buy stuff to make your character
stronger but I need a little bit more
money before I go and do that you get
money by killing these monsters and also
by especially by killing the enemy
so I haven't killed anybody yet but I
haven't died so that's good I need a
little bit more money the next item I
want to buys costs sixteen hundred
seventy five dollars and I have 1604 so
I'm gonna kill these guys and then go
back alright I have enough money to get
my first item I'm gonna go back and buy
it it'll make me stronger in the jungle
and nobody else has died yet so so far
so good
one more person died on my team you got
to start getting better here so why I
love teemo's you can plant these
mushrooms here and it gives you vision
so I can see in the jungle and if the
enemy steps on it they blow up alright I
got my first kill oh look guys coming
for me
so this jungle roll is very strategic
where you have to think about where they
are and not fall into too many traps
it's hard when you can't see
I'm really low on health here I'm gonna
go back I don't have a lot of health
actually I'm gonna put one more mushroom
down here for vision and then go back so
I bought boots that will make me faster
and then help potions so that I can I
don't have to come back next time I'm
really low on health
we're losing where three kills seven
deaths so not the greatest start but
hopefully we can still turn things
around I'm gonna give some vision so we
can see what's going on and hopefully we
turn this thing out
I believe oh we are losing team members
by the minute
three kills ten deaths so far
now my team is starting to disagree
somebody seen your pork bottom report
bottom report means you you tell on them
and you say they're not good players or
they're feeding or they're they're dying
on purpose or you know you're
complaining about them we don't have we
don't have good team harmony right now
but that happens sometimes when you're
losing I try just to do my best and do
what I'm good at and hopefully that
leads to some assists and kills and
turns this thing around it's a team game
and you don't know the people who you're
up with or against so it's hard to
coordinate a lot of stuff and if there's
hate it's hard to oh this guy's Martin's
about to die here you know I see him
dying so I can come and try to help but
all right we got a kill i got an assist
on that because he stepped on my
mushroom and hopefully we can turn this
game around people it's hard goes and
you fall behind the enemy gets a lot
stronger and then they can go out and
buy items to get even stronger so it
makes it difficult to catch up when you
fall too far behind but we're we're 5 5
deaths and no 5 kills and 10 deaths so
we're we're not too far behind but we
are far behind
we're gonna get this guy yeah good job
what I try to do too is when we do
something well just be happy you know
say say good job compliment people
because people are really you can find
negative people here whoa I'm getting
pounced on all right I'm going to do I'm
going to use some potions and heal up
oh he got me he killed me my potions
didn't work fast enough first death
well this game is not looking too good
at the moment six kills 13 deaths that's
that's starting to get a little out of
hand they need to make a mistake here
for us to to catch up and do better oh
they want to surrender let's see what
they vote now no seems to be I'll go no
just to support them but you can
surrender up to 20 minutes of plane
where we're just at 20 minutes so
basically he's I mean that shows how
demoralized my team is as soon as you
can surrender my team said let's
surrender all right well I got a kill
but my ally died with me to get that so
not doing too well here people 9 kills
16 deaths can we turn it around
so I am officially two kills two deaths
three assists my team is 10 kills 17
deaths Oh Oh 11 kills 17 deaths turning
around maybe let's see let's see
I believe my mushroom is it gonna kill
him
no I gotta kill there
I got another kill there Teemo and the
jungle people that's what happens yeah
another kill Teemo five and two friends
turning it around 14 and 17 for the team
that's what I'm saying man slowly
turning the tide let's see if we can
keep it up good job you know you get a
little momentum people start to get a
little back into it you know we haven't
seen another surrender vote come out so
that's good
well my team is fighting again now we're
doing well guys 15 18 I got another kill
I'm six and two - gotta get some
momentum back for the team though
they're feeling demoralized at least one
person is anybody can ask for a
surrender and then the whole team votes
on it so so my team there's somebody
who's not happy but I'm gonna just keep
doing my best setting up vision you know
vision really helps because if you can
see what's going on and people you know
the enemy is in the jungle you know
where they are you're less likely to die
you know it's kind of important so I
have some money I'm gonna do one thing
and then go back and get some more items
my team just died two more times again I
really should go back and get money use
my money to buy something but we're kind
of fighting here so
[Music]
it eased off a bit I'm gonna go back
another kill seven kills two deaths for
me team is at 18 kills 21 death so it's
a good comeback we're maybe gonna catch
Caitlyn here
oh my team's fighting and we don't have
a lot of people oh he's dead
you went too deep you got too greedy
don't be too greedy Oh team is hurting
I've got another kill
another kill I'm godlike well I'm trying
to help my team yo I'm nine and nine
kills to death seven assists but my rest
of my team isn't doing so well so but
don't complain just try to help
nice 27:27 we've ended up and I am ten
and two
so I'm ten kills two deaths eight
assists and the team is 27 and 27 so
we're tied so we've had a pretty good
comeback hopefully my team can not die
and we can pull this thing out we have
taken the lead 31 kills - 27 good job
team good job let's keep it up alright I
got a pile of money gonna go back buy
some new stuff we are at what I'm 11
kills two deaths 12 assists and our team
is 36 kills
27 deaths so that's a that's a pretty
good comeback friends but it's not over
yet not over yet oh we just lost a
member so great to have vision
everywhere so I'm 12 that 12 kills two
deaths 14 assists and our team is 40
kills 29 deaths it's a huge comeback
super excited about that Teemo jungle we
believe
oh that's not looking good
my team is dying my team is dying and I
got out with my life
whoo that was close no that wasn't great
we walked into a big scene of death
slowly they're coming back ones back so
sad
my third death thirteen and three I'm
back in four seconds
two one run
oh no we're one man down the Blanc
disconnected no playing five against
four that's not good that is not good oh
my gosh okay well that could be the end
it's just me alive because my my fourth
teammate is dead alright sorry he's just
sitting there
disconnected oh well that looks like
we're gonna lose
that's what happens when you're 45 oh
well good game we lost we lost yeah when
you're when you're down a person it's
really hard to come back so I'll just
say oh wow good game
so I ended up with 14 kills three deaths
21 assists which is uh the best ratio
and the team I had the most gold of
anybody Oh No
Caitlyn got more gold than me but anyway
we lost could have been better but we
lost
that's league of legends so Victor that
was for you hopefully you enjoyed I wish
I could given you the victory coming out
of that game but seriously thank you so
much for the love you're showing on the
channel giving ideas on how to make it
better
I really appreciate it you guys like
this video subscribe to the channel and
keep the ideas phone you got an idea for
me leave it in the comments a lot of
ceno's come in and makes a huge
difference for me every day so thank you
so much believe and I'll see you soon
don't forget to sign up for my free
newsletter its energy in your inbox
every single week hi I'm Jason Grif on
sigur rós online.com and I want to say
Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and it's the
only newsletter I prioritize and look
forward to period